thank you all think it's a pleasure to
be here as an aside I was in graduate
school in law and at Columbia and I
watched this building get built in in by
history IA wanted to be an architect
actually and I remember when this
slanted the area here and I looked and I
said to myself why are they building it
that way one day I guess I'll walk into
this building and I never did until
actually today when I had an opportunity
now I understand why it's slanted like
it is they're so good evening I'm
delighted to be here tonight to
commemorate your graduation from this
esteemed University let me first say
congratulations to all of you you have
reached the end of a long journey and
finally mph from Columbia so I applaud
all of you for your work your effort
your sacrifices that were required to
achieve this goal and I am sure that
there is a spouse a friend apparent a
significant other somebody saying I
lived it with him I lived it with her
because I know and when when I went back
to school for graduate school I remember
so my friends saying we lived this with
you so it's it's not uncommon to know
that there's a lot of support and family
so to them all those people have helped
you out i would say to them ask for a
nice dinner out for tonight that would
be a nice thank you and as you know i
attended Columbia as I just said many
years ago and also taught at the Medical
School for 10 years and given that many
or most of you are in mid-career I
thought maybe I tell you that for me
getting my masters in law was how I
solved my midlife crisis and mid life is
certainly an interesting time and
mid-career is an interesting time but it
can also be a time of turmoil to be one
filled with questions and self-doubt and
I sort of looked about that and thought
about I said what am I going to do with
my life and that and that's one of the
questions which i'm sure everyone asks
like do I want to continue in this path
to I want to change is it time to change
and I realize some people solve these
crises and not know what to do by buying
a red Porsche that has been known to
happen and other options are out there
as well that sometimes people pursue and
there are those who just shift gears in
their career where they decide a new
path
in their career so indulge me for a
moment while I share with you briefly
the story of four people who like those
of you in the room did just that they
changed their career they follow their
dream and they took a new path and
they're Julia and Harland and the timin
teen and Nina so we'll start with Julia
so as a child she dreamed of being a
novelist but at 29 she did something way
different it was World War two and she
became a spy for the US government and
she was working for the agency that
would later become the CIA and she
traveled to exotic places she was in
China she was in Sri Lanka Sri lady
top-secret documents between the u.s.
government officials and intelligence
officers but then she discovered that
her real passion was French cooking and
so life took a drastic turn for her and
she co-authored a mastering the art of
french cooking book and she had a
cooking show and for decades after the
name julia child's was synonymous with
food and cooking and then there was
harland and he started his career
running a Shell Oil Company in the south
and a shell station that's sold food too
weary travelers that were out there and
included in this cell things he sold was
his special recipe that he had and then
business started to dwindle at the time
and it began putting his energies into
improving his chicken dish they traveled
around the country and he took his
special recipe with him and then in 1952
he sold his first franchise in Utah and
more franchises started to crop up
around the country but by the time he
cashed out for all of two million
dollars which today would get you a very
nice small one-bedroom apartment with a
partial Central Park View but but that
was in 1964 Kentucky Fried Chicken had
become a household name and her own
Sanders became Colonel Sanders as we
know him and had 600 franchise
restaurants and then lastly there is Tim
a corporate lawyer together with his
wife Nina and they attended a dinner
party here in New York City in 1979 and
one of the guests complained about their
newspaper restaurants reviews that they
did claim
very unreliable and the data was not
correct and the other the guests that
the hotel said at the restaurant said
the same thing they agreed so Tina Tim
and Nina decide they would do something
completely different they would compile
all the opinions of all these critics
they put it together they survey the
2200 amateur critics they'd grade the
100 restaurants and put on legal paper
tim was a lawyer and Zagat's guide was
born and as an aside as major as an
aside about 45 years ago I was at a
dinner party and I was talking to some
people and I asked them what they did
and the gentleman standing there was
talking his wife was standing next to
him and he said well we sort of review
restaurants and see how they are and
what they whether they're good or
they're not and then we grade them and I
said oh you mean like the Zagat's and
they said we are the Zagat's so which is
exactly what happens you never know who
you with so Julia and Harlan Tim and
Nina all them were mid-career changes
and in fact Harlan was way beyond
midlife or mid career in midlife because
he used his first social security check
to start kentucky fried chicken so it's
unbelievable what ages I about 6500 make
a big change so changing career paths
takes courage it takes courage to give
up security and income and and home and
family that your lifestyle and and you
just do it to pursue dreams and dreams
that may be uncertain and time-consuming
and often very expensive and i'm sure
you all you all of you have wondered is
it worth it will I fail but here in
mid-career you might be wanting for a
desperate change and though as I
mentioned before some may say a red
Porsche would do that may bring joy but
a more worthwhile investment is what all
of you did which is a mid-career
education and it's a chance to do some
good for the world and you in this room
know what I'm talking about you have
made the commitment to change to create
change whether it's pursuing work in
completely new fields or adjusting to
the one that you're in and here you are
physicians and surgeons university
presidents professors and hospital
leaders consultants and advocates
dedicated professionals in your
respective fields who have
mitted yourself to a program that brings
a public health perspective to your work
as a perspective that has the potential
to alter the course of your careers and
maybe the course of mankind as well
unlike abstract scientist it should be
humankind because we should be correct
right humankind as well unlike abstract
scientific fields like physics where
break big breakthroughs were made mostly
by scientists early in their career at a
physicist a classmate of mine from
college once said to me that if you
don't make your big physics break by the
time you're 30 that's it and I remember
on his 30th birthday the first thing I
did a head on my little calendar i said
call Chris and said how you're doing it
was not well and he had not made his big
physics career breakthrough it he knew
because all physicists you they may not
reporting it may not publish it but they
have it in their mind at that point but
great discoveries in public health took
place in the middle of someone's career
sometimes after life experiences gave
them the wisdom the perspective and the
opportunity to be in the world and to
see what was out there in history
teaches us that great things can come
out of midlife especially in the world
of public health so the physician Jon
Snow for instance was 41 when he traced
London's cholera epidemic in 1854 to a
water pump on Broad Street a pump that
still stands in that same soho
neighborhood and its discovery put an
end to an epidemic that his devastate
had devastated the city at that time and
recently one of my really good friends
it just was about 34 weeks ago came back
from a trip to london and i said to her
you know how was it was great she said i
can i show you some pictures i said sure
I said she said let me show you my
favorite and it wasn't London's Tower of
London it wasn't Buckingham Palace she
shows me a picture of the grounds
because this is where the pump was right
here only a public health person would
say this is my favorite picture in all
of my trip to London and also graduated
this program your program as well so
coincidentally has same year emil von
bearing the german physiologist was born
when that happened and he was 53 when he
published a paper showing that a
combination of antitoxin and toxin could
prevent diphtheria the discovery that
ultimately led to the diphtheria vaccine
and enter disease that also killed
millions and here in America there was
Jonas Salk who in 1914 was born and at
43 in 1957 he introduced the polio
vaccine that put an end to a disease
which caused National terror and
according to some surpassing our fear of
atomic weapons and perhaps if you took a
survey today I've a if you ask people
about Ebola they would probably say
that's on the top of the list and
they're not so worried about some of the
other things so I think for a moment
it's great a concern as the stock market
collapse or Isis or nuclear
proliferation was or is few things
create more angst than biological agents
and create more worried than public
health it's always a big issue that
happens and so today our minds can't
help but gravitate obviously to West
African Sierra Leone to getting to
Liberia where we think of Public Health
where the Ebola virus has obviously
tragically claimed for thousands to five
thousand lives and the looming threat of
this deadly virus has spawned fair
across the globe but this is hardly the
first epidemic that has seized our our
borders or or immigration from other
parts of America have immigrated to our
country or to other parts of the world
but it's also has seized our imagination
in many ways 12 years ago we were in the
grips of another crisis which was SARS
and sorrow severe acute respiratory
syndrome spread to 37 countries in just
a matter of a few weeks in a second
about 8,000 people in the early 1980s we
were struck by AIDS an epidemic that was
particularly difficult for New York
State and for New York City as its
claimed many millions of lives since
that time when it began and today along
with Ebola we have the enterovirus 68
that has emerged after 52 years of
dormancy and that Rip Van Winkle virus
has spread to 46 week US 46 states and
as a week in many people's lives and
infected many children and is also
killed about six and even diseases that
once essentially a rat we're eradicated
have made a revival performance in some
parts of the world so last spring the
World Health Organization sounded the
alarm again on polio as a public health
emergency of international concern
we were so close so close to completely
eradicate e this paralyzing disease and
had enjoyed successes in many places
that had once been devastated by polio
India once had millions of cases a year
in the head its last kiss three years
ago and the US had his last naturally
occurring case in 1979 when the disease
struck the Amish community in the
Midwest but now it says polios reemerged
in Africa and in the Middle East with
the potential to spread again around the
world and according to the world health
organization if unchecked this situation
could result in failure to eradicate
globally one of the world's most serious
vaccine-preventable diseases but
infectious diseases as we all very
worried about those are only one facet
of public health as you all know it's
the one that gets detention it's the
splashy headlines as we have seen but
nothing pull as we all know nothing
pulls at the heartstrings and the
pocketbooks of something like a virus
where there's no treatment and that can
cause a lot of morbidity and mortality
but public health is also about teaching
parents about the benefits of
breastfeeding about finding the tools
that will stop global obesity by making
preparations for disasters even natural
or made by humans it's about encouraging
men who have sex with men to use condoms
about banning e-cigarettes or
intervening with an opioid drug user dr.
shops around around the state or around
the country so how you define and
practice public health at this juncture
in your career depends on your
experience and your background for the
dental profession it may involve
developing rural clinics to deliver oral
health services to areas where dental
care is truly lacking for hospital
executives it might be incentives that
boosts flu vaccination rates among the
hospital staff or exercise programs
promoting weight loss and from
pharmaceutical professionals it perhaps
is devising ways to stem the growing
heroin epidemic or maybe in the midst of
all this there's those who are working
labs with test tubes and pipettes and PC
are doing the research that will lead to
the cure for Ebola or for any of the
other diseases aids or dearly dreamin
also cancer the possibilities in public
health are endless because public health
is endless from our local communities to
the world at large
as the future stewards of this
profession of passionate optimists which
I think everyone public health is you
will inherit these challenges finding
solutions demands creative thinking and
hutzpah and that's in New York you could
say that be from the Bronx that's a word
that is commonly used or in my
upbringing it requires a code spec to
seize the child's and tribulations that
are out there and turn them into the
opportunities to improve the world we
live in just as John Snowden emil von
bearing jonas salk did in their day you
have the opportunity to do it today as
people in the middle of your careers you
are in the perfect place to effect the
change that is needed think of it as a
mid-career opportunity and like Julia
and Harlan and Tina and Tim and Nina you
already know how the world works what
people want what they need what people
are willing to accept what they're
willing to do and that's why Julia Child
could shift gears from spider chef in
the middle of her life so be the spy
that finds the elusive cure to cancer
and that's why Colonel Sanders was able
to perfect his fried chicken to the
national sensation even as he stood at
the brink of retirement so designed the
franchise that has a health food
restaurant as its theme so that people
don't have to go out to all the fast
food restaurants are not healthy for
them and lets me forget the gods who
created their guides and gave people
service they didn't even know they need
so give people services that they may
not need as well that involve public
health as working professionals you have
the unique insights into the world of
health care health policy nonprofit
companies academics and all the other
fields that you come to this degree with
and these are careers that you will only
build upon through your experience you
know how to make an impact and where
your leadership skills will be needed
most whatever you do remember this
public health transforms lives in fact
few things have had more impact in
improving life expectancy and public
health I'm sure from the first day of
public health school you were told that
may be in before the school during
orientation cherish that fact across the
globe we've eradicated smallpox the
disease that killed millions over
thousands of years and the USD we
enacted the Clean Air Act and that's
saved 22
million and prevented 250,000 premature
deaths at this moment in New York State
we stand poised to finally end the
epidemic of AIDS the state has taken
this on we will keep moving forward we
had a major meeting about this just two
days ago so today as you receive your
freshly minted degrees in public health
you have the opportunity to merge your
knowledge with established careers to
forge that new path a new journey as
Yogi Berra says when you come to the
fork in the road take it Julia Holland
Tim and Nina all chose the culinary
environment to change the world but you
you're the proud servants of Public
Health and while colonel sanders
continues to tempt us with his finger
licking good chicken by the way one
piece also has about 400 calories and 28
grams of fat so I probably wouldn't eat
that you'll be looking for ways to stem
the epidemics of diabetes and obesity
you'll be searching for ways to cure the
latest infectious diseases improving the
lives of people in our communities and
the communities around the world is a
noble mission and well worth the effort
as I close I will let you know about a
trip that I once took to a village about
150 miles from maputo mozambique it was
an AIDS clinic and when I noticed all
the medicines and how well stocked the
clinic was I asked the person ran the
clinic how is this that your clinic is
so well prepared and some of the others
aren't and unbeknownst to me a nurse
trimmed up and said because of Columbia
University's public health school in New
York City and Alan Rosenfeld who is a
Dean of the school before at present
Dean for they make sure we have what we
need so I just leave you knowing that
the school touches so many different
people in so many parts of the world and
I leave with my favorite quote the quote
that gets put on my desk every time I
move and I've moved a lot over the years
before I put anything else out i put out
this quote it's from Margaret Mead and
says don't underestimate the power of a
few people to change the world that's
all that ever has so congratulations and
may you change the world each and every
one of you as you move forth and take on
your public health degree and save all
the problems and solve all the problems
and save many people around the world
thank you
you